- JOIN HANDS.
- OKAY.
- I DON'T WANT TO.
- COME ON.
- [bleep] ASSHOLE.
- SPIRITS OF THE PAST,
MOVE AMONG US.
BE GUIDED BY THE LIGHT
OF THIS WORLD,
AND VISIT UPON US.
- [imitates fart]
EW, SHE TOOTED,
GROSS!
DID YOU GUYS HEAR THAT?
- WE SUMMON YOU TO JOIN US
AT THIS TABLE,
AND HONOR YOUR PRESENCE
THIS EVENING.
- YOU THINK SHE LIKES
WHITE BOYS?
- REPEAT THIS CHANT AFTER ME.
SPIRIT, YOU ARE WELCOME.
- BLAH, BLAH, BLAH, BLAH.
all: SPIRIT, YOU ARE WELCOME.
- LEAVE THE DARKNESS, COME!
- COME! [laughs] COME,
LIKE JIZZ, LIKE EJACULATE.
- COME OUT OF THE DARKNESS,
INTO THE LIGHT.
[speaking in tongues]
- [opens a can]
- WHO DARES DISGRACE MY CHAMBERS
WITH ALCOHOL?
- I DON'T KNOW.
- YOUR PRESENCE WILL WELCOME
UNWANTED ENTITIES.
[groaning]
AH, YOU...
ARE CURSED!
- REMEMBER WHEN SHE TOOTED
EARLIER? [laughs]
[theme music plays]